[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
happy happy happy hump day oh
it's a great day for democracy
that's right celebrate celebrate
celebrate but do not forget
why we are so excited
because you engaged in your democracy
the people in kansas
the people in other states engaged in in
our democracy oh my gosh right here look
at this
look at this what's going on here i get
lazy i get lazy with my hair i guess i
don't know who knows
well i got a special guest for you today
at the bottom of the hour david bender
the political strategist is going to
come tell us why he has all the
experience in the world decades and
decades of experience and political
strategy and he's going to give us a
breakdown of what happened yesterday in
the primaries in certain states like
arizona like missouri like kansas like
michigan where he's going to help break
us down what happened what this shows
why we should be so excited and why this
should get us to engage even more that's
right
that's right
last night what happened proves
that democracy wins kansas has proven
that democracy wins
let's all be kansas
let's all be kansas
i know that sounds weird
for people blue vote for kansas but
kansas has plenty plenty
of history of liberal democracy
it has a lot of history of liberal
democracy it has a a woman who is a
democrat as the governor
there's plenty of reason to believe
that these red states these red states
like kansas missouri texas
arizona georgia
they're not really red
they're not
they practice in liberal democracy just
like you want to no matter what spectrum
you're on
on the political ideology scale
they're not fascist they don't want
their [ __ ] rights taken away from
them
regardless if you consider yourself a
moderate and independent a democrat a
liberal a socialist
a conservative
even people who self-proclaim themselves
a conservative went yesterday in kansas
to make sure to secure the right for
women to their bodily autonomy
because the white men in kansas wanted
to take it the [ __ ] away from them
so the next move for kansas is to vote
out
every one of them son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] who wanted to over who wanted to
overturn their right to their bodily
autonomy
and the supreme court said no
and this referendum on the ballot
which
again the referendum was rigged against
them and they still stomp the [ __ ] out
of them my view is
they rigged the language on the
referendum
so
because you had to vote no
on the on the referendum
to to get a yes on your rights right
that's how they were trying to rig it
because they thought it would be close
they knew it would be close at least
that's what their initial thought was so
they thought if we can rig up this
referendum language we might be able to
pull four or five percent
of people who vote
the opposite direction of what they
actually want to vote
that's how they do this [ __ ] they do it
in my state they do it in several states
all the time where they make the
referendum language very [ __ ]
confusing
so that way if there's a small margin it
can sway one way or the other
but it was a [ __ ] blowout
it was a [ __ ] blowout
women in kansas said nope
[ __ ] around with our health care and
you'll find out
huge turnout
turnouts that we haven't seen since 2008
in the presidential election when barack
obama was elected president
in a mid-term primary
think about that on a referendum
all because all because a bunch of dumb
[ __ ]
wanted to buy and pay for a few supreme
court justices to make sure to overturn
people's rights that they don't want
them to have
and they they have awakened a sleeping
giant
because it's not just the women in
kansas it's the men who stand behind
those women who are ready to fight for
their their daughter's rights their
wife's rights their sister's rights
their mother's rights hell their own
goddamn rights to contraception as a man
who they can and can't love who the who
they can and can't [ __ ]
they can and can't marry they're ready
to fight
this is democracy folks you're seeing it
in front of you this is why i've been
saying that democracy terrifies [ __ ]
terrifies fascists
because it is what it is what eventually
leads to equity and equality and they
hate them some equity inequality
so why would they like democracy that's
why they're always like oh we're not a
democracy we're a republic you've heard
this stupid [ __ ]
we're republic
yeah you're you're democratic
constitutional republic
so is kansas and last night kansas
constitutional democratic republic
the exercise was in full display
we're going to show you video from the
celebration in kansas for those people
who worked so hard on the ground
to make sure the word was out about how
to vote
because of the language was confusing in
the referendum
adam kinsinger is also on a tirade this
morning about democrats are the same as
republicans if you're wondering like i'm
i'm grateful that adam kensinger
has done what he's done on the select
committee but my my love for adam
kensinger stops right about [ __ ]
there
both sides
he's got language this morning
on cnn of all places talking about both
sides both sides the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
he's mad he's mad that a representative
who voted to impeach trump the democrats
put money in
to make sure that the trumpy the trump
endorsed candidate would win and the
reason why the reason why folks there's
a [ __ ] reason why democrats didn't
just put 400 grand in this race
for nothing
the numbers bear out that this trump
candidate
has the best chance of losing which
creates us a seat
and anne mckinsinger is mad is mad
that the democrats are playing rough
with republicans [ __ ] you adam kinsinger
[ __ ] you that's right i said it
he should be cheering the democrats are
fighting for democracy here oh well i
don't want to hear anything about
democrats
being pro-democracy
for years we've heard democrats don't
fight hard enough
well in this race in in michigan when
the results bear out
when this trump candidate loses and
there's a democrat sitting in that seat
then you'll know what democracy looks
like you'll know what a fight looks like
the dnc is finally [ __ ] start to pick
some [ __ ] fights
it's about goddamn time and adam
kinsinger can take his both sides talk
and shove it up his [ __ ] ass because
that's what delivered us trump is that
bull side [ __ ] i say it all the time
here and anyone anyone anyone out there
who talks about both sides both parties
the same they're not pro-democracy
they're not they're [ __ ] gaslighting
you they're [ __ ] lying
the parties are not the same
they haven't been for a long god damn
time because we have one party in this
country that is interested in democracy
and the other party wants to destroy
it one party wants autocracy one party
wants to participate and engage in
democracy
you [ __ ] figure it out and if you
can't figure it out then you got [ __ ]
problems bonehead
so if you can't figure out which party
is for democracy which one's for
autocracy then pluck your head out of
your ass adam kinzinger and realize
you're not welcome in the autocracy
party anymore you're not welcome there
because you're not for autocracy
so just drop the whole bull side [ __ ]
dummy
i'm gonna show you the tape i got a lot
of [ __ ] video to go through today a
lot of [ __ ] video we have so much
video from yesterday we have even video
from the alex jones trial where after
the jury leaves a room
speaking of boneheads
the judge absolutely deep pantses
ah
tears down alex jones in front of the in
front of his
his defense
and in front of the courtroom now the
jury was out of the room because he was
lying on the stand yesterday and she had
to warn him several times she's like
stop stop that's a lie and i've been
watching a little bit of it this morning
and she's been doing the same thing alex
jones is probably going to end up in the
jail cell for contempt because he just
won't listen to this [ __ ] judge he
won't he won't follow the [ __ ] rules
she said yesterday this is not your show
this is not your show alex this is not
your show [ __ ]
you don't get to say whatever the [ __ ]
you want on this stand you're under oath
you have to tell the truth and you will
be held accountable to that truth
anything that's obviously not true that
you know is not true is not going to be
admissible in court
and she warned him
now again it's very confusing to me and
i really i really need to bring on uh
either karen agnipolo or maybe popock
to get
to really get a sense of what this trial
is about because he's already lost but
this trial is to decide how much
how much he's going to lose right
like how much money not his freedom i i
mean
the january 6 select committee
and the doj may take his freedom away
for his
his participation in the coup d'etat the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup
but
i digress on that
they're gonna decide
if he's bankrupt or not that was
actually one of the contentions and
you'll see it in the video that the
judge is like you're not bankrupt you
just filed bankruptcy and everyone was
uh
talking about the scene from the office
when michael scott says i declare
bankruptcy like that's all you got to do
just say you're bankrupt and then you're
bankrupt it's legal once you just say
you're bankrupt alex jones you're a
[ __ ] clown you're a [ __ ]
boon
head apparently elizabeth hasselbeck has
also said some dumb [ __ ] on the view
this morning so we're going to try to
track down that tape
now we're also going to track down some
tape of carrie lake
carrie lake claimed yesterday we watched
the tape with von hilliard pressuring
carrie lake into showing him some
evidence of voter fraud and she wouldn't
do it
she wouldn't do it
von hilliard and msdnc
would be the last people she shows
evidence of and he's like why haven't
you taken it to authorities if you
really say for so fraud why do you take
it to authorities the simple matter of
the fact is carrie lake is a [ __ ]
liar she's a [ __ ] liar she's a god
damn a liar
i'd welcome carrie lake on this show if
she would bring us some evidence i'm not
the i'm not the i'm not the mainstream
media let's do it carrie
you [ __ ] bonehead
but kerry lake claims that they were
going to steal the election even last
night in her acceptance speech
claimed that there was all kinds of
nefarious stuff there was fraud
but she won
she declared she won
because she was thinking she wasn't
going to edge this out it looked like
it looked like
carrie lake wouldn't win
and then and then we had a huge voting
dump
ballot dumps overnight can you imagine
can you imagine in this country in this
democracy and and america
that there be overnight ballots dropped
it's obvious it's obvious that it's
fraud
we need to stop the steel and make sure
carrie lake isn't the case i want carrie
lake to be the candidate to be frank
with you
no i'd i'd prefer that that crazy kooky
[ __ ] box be the candidate
same reason why they want this this uh
this trumped-up candidate in michigan in
in mayor's district that adam kinsinger
is so upset about
same reason same [ __ ] reason same
reason why i was hoping eric greitens
that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] lunatic would win in
missouri but he lost he had his ass
kicked
oh my god even vicky hartzler
who wasn't polling at all whipped his
ass
eric greitens lost handily here in
missouri
to eric schmidt the other eric
you know
i wonder who else was betting
on and eric to win
oh in true fashion
trump hedges his bit
hedges his bet on eric and eric wins
eric schmidt wins but don't get it
twisted eric schmidt is just as much of
a piece of [ __ ]
as eric greitens that's right the guy
who duct taped his hairdresser naked to
a treadmill took pictures of her and
used those pictures as blackmail for her
to perform sex acts on him
eric schmidt is just much of a piece of
[ __ ] i'm saying it right here
and over the next few months maybe we'll
just show why eric schmidt is such a
piece of [ __ ]
i've experienced him firsthand
in my state of
taking my tax dollars
and spending it on his campaign
probably talk more about that when david
bender comes on
now back to kansas
because i think kansas is very important
here today
it's very important
the reason why kansas is so important
is because there are other
there are other
states
that their makeup
is very similar to kansas
what do i mean by that what i mean by
that is there are some states like texas
georgia
some other like i said what i said
before red states
arizona florida may be another one
that their makeup
is very similar to kansas
that those voters there aren't
necessarily a hundred percent gonna vote
gqpq and on every time
when you start to when you start to
prove that these candidates
are extremist
their fascist america first nazis these
christian nationalists
that are willing to tell you
with their big fascist government what
you can and cannot do
what health care you can and cannot
receive
what contraception you can and cannot
use they see that as a very slippery
slope
even pro-life women who who self-declare
themselves pro-life went and made sure
to secure
the bodily autonomy
for exceptions rape and incest folks do
you know why the pro-life movement never
never
targeted women directly it was always
about the clinics it was always about
the politicians it was always about the
organizations
because of those three little things
they knew they knew that they needed
women in their movement and the only way
to keep women in their movement
was to have an exception for the woman's
life
for rape and incest that language alone
kept women in their movement for decades
and actually perpetuated
the situation that we're in now
to overturn roe v wade
as a political issue
but this is this dobbs case where
they've overturned roe v wade with their
bought and paid for fascist court
is a situation where the dog has caught
the car
and last night we
we witnessed the dog
getting caught underneath the wheel
i had a discussion with someone last
night and they said well this is good
news this is good news
this row thing if we keep pushing this
i'm like wait a second
i believe this road decision on dobbs to
overturn women's rights to their bodily
autonomy is now
baked in the cake folks
that's right
we're gonna have to work hard we're
gonna have to engage
a lot
to make sure that democrats not only
keep the house they increase their
majority
not only keep the senate but increase
their majority but we win governor's
races we win secretary of state races we
win backs legit state
folks
this decision
is baked
into the cake at some point here
i believe that's the proof out of kansas
that's super important
because we have the january 6 select
committee
that isn't quite baked in our cake yet
so we have now until november to make
sure
that that cake is done
we the people
with the help of so many women
so many women
in kansas to prove and men who support
women and who support women's rights
so many
people in kansas prove to us last night
that democracy can win
that when you actually get out there
and you do the thing called voting
and you engage in your democracy not
just not just marking your ballot
but getting the word out
making sure that people understand
exactly
exactly what is at stake
you can win and not only can you win you
can trounce these [ __ ]
to rounds
them
and it's time
it's time to do democracy that's what
it's time to do
and this election the 2022 midterm is
the most important election of your
lifetime
to engage in democracy and as soon
as those ballots are counted and this
midterm is over the next election will
be the most important one
and we have to use our tools to
politicize
every single
issue
and your main tool is the power of your
ballot
and again i'm not just talking about
marking your vote
i'm talking about knocking doors giving
money to campaigns so they can pay
for goods and supplies and energy to
knock doors water food
flyers
call text
send letters for a campaign somewhere
whatever it may be that your talent is
it may just be yapping into a microphone
or talking to folks on the ground
that you know your family your friends
it's going to be super important
to engage
in your democracy
just like they did in kansas
so let's all be kansas
let's all be sick and tired of this
trumpism [ __ ]
because i believe that's where this come
from
trumpism wants to take away your rights
trumpism wants to tell you how to live
and who to be
what religion
whether you're in the kitchen barefoot
or not
whether you're pregnant or not whether
you have to be a ten-year-old should be
forced to carry
her rapist baby to term
they want to tell you what the [ __ ] to
do
and the fascists are at the front door
it's real
but we're here to fight and we're on the
team baby
we're on the team
so let's go team democracy
let's
go team democracy
every single weekday you will hear me do
my pro-democracy
bit
here on the tony michaels podcast noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific every
single weekday for two hours youtube
twitter and twitch so go to the youtube
page if you're not there already and
subscribe to the tony michaels podcast
it's super important that you listen to
every single episode we also simulcast
from the mind as touch facebook page so
if you're over there on facebook come
over here to youtube click subscribe
you're not going to want to miss a video
and today we have an important
announcement about bonehead of the week
go to tonymichaelspod on twitter
and follow us there for today because
usually we put out the poll on thursdays
it's going to come out today
so you can start to vote sometime today
for bonehead of the week and boy
boy do we have a whole list choose from
i think gabe's gonna have a very
difficult time choosing who is the bone
end of the week
are the candidates as it were you choose
the bonehead of the week
we break it down on fridays in the
second hour of the tony michaels podcast
so don't miss that also go download
every single episode on apple spotify
google your favorite directory make sure
to leave us a great review five star
review right there we thank everyone
who's been leaving reviews
to drown out the trolls we had some
trolls come on our thing and they they
left a lot of stupid bad reviews
so go if whatever directory you're on
apple spotify google whatever directory
it may be leave us a great review there
if you would please that would help us
out a lot
but stay tuned
stay tuned and get engaged
we're gonna fire you up here every
single weekday monday through friday for
two full hours i have a ton of video to
get to
today
and i have a special guest uh i believe
he should be here soon um david bender
the political strategist yes it looks
like he's gonna be here soon uh david
bender the political the great political
strategist will be here soon joining us
after the break stick around don't go
anywhere
we will be right back after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50 a day
you can help us help those true
americans recover from biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those trump
supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back back back
to the show thanks for joining us thank
you for sticking around due to break uh
looks like there's some some uh news
that's coming in here um maybe
yesterday but it kind of got buried
um it's kansas news but it got buried
underneath all the other kansas news um
apparently there's a former united
states rep tim
holtz camp
right
um he was sending out fake text messages
saying women in kansas are losing their
choice on reproductive rights voting yes
on the amendment will give women the
choice they were so desperate seeing
this is what i'm talking about this is
what i'm talking about even when they
rigged the ballot even when they rigged
the language on the ballot they still
couldn't win
because everyone is engaged everyone is
organized
now i actually probably believe that
that it did sway and some people did buy
into this idea that they should vote yes
on that amendment and it would give them
the ability to save their and
codify their abortion rights
but these women these voters did not buy
into it
and not only did they did they win they
trounced the fascist in kansas they
absolutely trounced them um i want to
welcome a great political strategist
he's going to give us years and years
and years of his knowledge of what
happened
yesterday what this means not just for
for the democratic party but for
democracy because i think that is so
important and i think this political
strategist
brings that knowledge to us that it's
not just important for a political party
i've talked to him so many times on air
during the january 6 select i am i'm so
happy to have him back i haven't had a
chance yet we've been so busy i haven't
had a chance to thank him yet for
joining us on all those january 6
select hearings so i'd like to do it now
and i want to welcome
david bender david how are you
well i'm good and and
you're very welcome but you know i
charge per year do you years and years
and years of experience oh okay okay
well we're here so i you know you'll get
my bill absolutely send it over send it
over
actually you know
at a certain point we have a cap on it
when you get to decades
i do want to say first of all you're
welcome i i've been listening to the
show
this morning and and i think you're spot
on
what has happened david david i'm always
spot on i'm almost i'm always fun
i'll i'll call it the sweet spot
and and the sweet spot here is sweet for
a lot of people
who saw this
and i i'm
pleased to say i i was one of them this
was not a
i know that the polls
showed and let's let's agree now tony
that polls are insane in in the year in
which we live because we're not
polling people who actually vote we're
polling i i don't even know who answers
polls anymore and i know that there are
some people particularly uh the trumpist
uh or should call them the
fascist
cheeto dust people
these people
refuse to play along in fact they
mislead in what they're going to do so
let's i i think we've been pulling too
much for years
and the polls that showed that kansas
would be
close and possibly go the other way
had no clue
about how people were really motivated
and feeling in a way
that i think we saw the results
yesterday the the number of voters
exceeded the 2020 primary
a presidential year in an off year
uh in august i mean come on
people are deeply motivated when you
take away
something from them
and this is what the republicans
continually fail to understand
they were going to take away
obamacare because you know in 2010
everyone hated obamacare before they
knew what it was and they won big
victories campaigning against it they
thought oh we'll keep doing that
but they were fighting
the old war not realizing that once
people had it
and they liked it
you take it away from them
and they're
pissed off
now this is even
as significant as healthcare is
this is going to the lives and literally
the lives of women all across america no
matter their political party
and and what i found astounding last
night and i you know i have a great
regard for steve kornacki at msnbc i
think he's great with numbers
but he missed something which is unusual
for him but he missed it big time
he was talking about the biden vote in
counties and comparing that to the no
vote in kansas on the novo being keeping
abortion
and
he was comparing apples to oranges
this wasn't a democrat republican issue
right this was a human issue
and
the only thing now and the big question
with what is it 98 days left to the
november election
and and less than that to when people
start voting in october
is we've got to hang this around the
republicans next
every candidate for every office at
every level but particularly the us
house and senate
have to defend the supreme court and
have to defend their long record of
saying they want to take away a woman's
right to choose
because they've won that
for a while
and if they want to campaign on that in
november
good luck to them in
dark red districts like kansas good luck
to those republicans who have to run on
their record now if the democrats are
not a circular firing squad the
democrats figure out a way
to aim at the republicans and not one
another
this is a target that is so fat
and so obvious
and you just shoot them with their own
ammunition they've given us that weapon
years and years 40 years of we're gonna
do this thing
okay as you said they caught the car
they should choke on the exhaust pipe
right well the wheel is on top of them
for sure i want to bring in my co-host
and uh a friend of ours gabe sanchez hey
gabe hey morning good morning good
morning so
um i want to talk about yesterday
because yesterday was big victories
there was more than just the midterms uh
yesterday we watched as the senate
pulled the pacnack over the line um we
this morning opec is announcing that
they're going to up production um which
is another win for this administration
but by them saying yes we're going to up
production to make sure the gas costs uh
keep going in the correct direction
which is downward they're so many so
many successes here that the
pro-democracy party are delivering to
american people and i think you're right
that they are noticing it's this this
this this polling where um joe biden has
a a a bad approval rating let me tell
you something the polls are wrong but
not only are they wrong
people aren't making their decisions
based on joe biden being the president
because joe biden is not threatening joe
biden is not threatening their rights
it's the republicans it's it's the kerry
lakes
it's it's the the the eric schmitz it's
it's these people in in michigan it is
herschel walker it is dr oz it is jd
vance it is ron desantis
these republicans like greg abbott and
some of these others are the ones who
are coming after your way of life but
just in the last 48 hours we've had so
many successes that are proving and i
believe and i said it this morning
that this idea of pro-democracy is now
starting to bake in the cake which is
super important and that is why we have
to keep pushing and pushing and pushing
and lean into politicizing these issues
i so many times um we get comments me
and gabe and i know david you probably
have heard this too democrats aren't
tough enough democrats don't fight hard
enough the messaging is horrible over
and over and over again
the one thing that democrats are
learning very quickly and the select
committee has kind of taught them this
and i don't know if liz cheney knows
this or not but i think she kind of
rubbed off on him a bit yeah
we are starting to politicize these
issues and we are winning by knowing
that politicizing them creates
engagement and engagement in the
democracy gets a result that gets closer
to equality and equity
i i i defer to gabe
yeah i think well i even think that some
of these issues like you know gas prices
and things like that we've got 19 states
that are below four dollars 15 states
that are below 389 like we're finding
that these issues that republicans have
made such a big deal about
are are not issues anymore and i
wouldn't be surprised that in the next
month that doesn't even become a talking
point anymore because it's not really
that important in the grand scheme in
the grand scheme you have to deal with
these people that you've identified as
these pro-fascist leaders or want to be
dictators that are attempting to rule
and reign over the people and take
rights away so i think for these other
things that they've made such a big deal
about like oh you know putting a sticker
on a gas pump saying i did that right
well it turns out those things have
actually backfired and it actually is
biden pointed at the gas price going
down i dropped it i dropped it i did
that the price is going down because of
me so you see these things that are
actual non-issues and i think again
probably the next month or so they won't
even be a talking point because
republicans will have dropped them
democrats will say we can mention it but
that's not the bigger problem that's at
stake right now so i think
um i think a lot of i mean i don't know
what other small things they're going to
complain about other than just
projecting but none of us can know and
that's
listen i have been doing this as we know
since grover cleveland second term not
fluid
where's my paw gone to the white house
ha ha ha
anyone anyway so
i'm sorry i don't remember that but
let's pretend i do here's here's what i
do want to say
we don't know gabe you're right we don't
know what the issues are going to be and
one of the things that i always
really chuckle at sometimes get annoyed
by
is the phrase if the election were held
today
because when someone says that
number one
they've never done a campaign
and number two
it never is because they're saying if it
were
when now we have october is an entire
voting month fewer states less
you know early voting but still october
is when voting starts
so it's
you know not one day but if if by the
end of september
we have a sense of what the american
people are focused on and what things
are driving people's
interest in wanting to vote
the end of september is going to be the
measurement and that is two months away
from now we've got some time and a lot
of things can change they always do
that's the one thing you can count on is
the unexpected
but let's look at what happened you just
ticked off a few of them let's mention
that uh alswahari has been taken out
that is an incredible victory that this
democratic president this so-called weak
on terrorism he abandoned afghanistan
well he took out the guy who was the
greatest threat and killed tens of
thousands of americans and and people
around the world civilians over
20 years 30 years of of running free of
30 years of this
this is
a huge victory that we all
should say
made this country safer because joe
biden was the president but you're right
it's not going to be about your budget
it shouldn't be
it should be about each of those this
election should be nationalized
but in each of those races you ticked
off tony in in uh you know with with the
the governor of michigan with the
governor of florida they should all be
forced to take positions
about their national views uh and and
they are views that are
anti-democratic
they are views that are anti-women
they're anti-environment
they're pro-gun
these are all
absolutely each one alone is devastating
and guess what september the month i
just talked about
this committee with liz cheney showing
you know democrats how to be strong
the committee will be meeting again
on primetime television in september
so
hey i'm looking forward to the new
season i can't wait to have you on for
the new season
any anytime anywhere you know
it is uh
listen this has been
one of the most
gratifying things i've gotten to work on
in my entire career was helping to work
with the groups that
organized and it was a coalition of
everybody it was 150 pro-democracy
groups indivisible and common cause all
these great groups coming together
to build attention we started work
months and ahead months ahead of
the first hearing june 9th
and you know i came on with you we
talked about this we had to build
awareness everyone said no one's going
to pay attention
it's a loser no ratings nothing's going
to happen
well when we started this
at the beginning of june public opinion
was about split on whether trump was
accountable and whether this was
important to look at and make any
difference and it was yesterday's news
it's now at two-thirds and growing right
it's going to break 70 and those are
numbers that no one can ignore
it's like the republicans finally
figured out they couldn't ignore the
veterans and had to turn their votes
around after the fist bump
on
trying to kill veterans benefits i want
that fist bump i'm sure you've got the
clip it should be over and over and over
yeah i i've got i've we've got we've got
any clip that you would want we got a
great executive producer here that can
i know
that can spit up any kind of clip that
you absolutely uh he just goes on
twitter
slow motion is always fun
i'll tell you speaking of clips and
speaking of the january six select
committee because i actually appreciate
the the talk about the organization
because i think that is the difference
last night because adam kinzinger he is
on the select committee and i am
grateful for what adam kinzinger is
doing for the select committee but this
morning he's on cnn both siding things
and the reason why is because a a a
representative a sitting incumbent a
republican peter meyer who voted against
or for impeaching trump lost last night
because democrats said hey if we're
going to play for democracy we better
play for the entire game and i think i
think
when you're upset when when you get adam
kinzinger upset in this in this way and
in this moment you know we're doing
something right and the organization is
intense i'm gonna i'm gonna have to
respectfully not disagree but sure
yellow light a flashing yellow light up
yeah absolutely
because playing with fire
can sometimes
burn you and go the wrong way mm-hmm
if gibbs the guy who
wound up the trumpist who wound up
winning that nomination winds up
winning the election
we've got another election denier in the
house
and now
in fairness the the strategy has shown
that the democrat is likely to beat this
extremist in a moderate you know this is
grand rapids this is gerald ford's old
district i i i get the strategy i do
but
i i do think and a lot of
smart
people who i respect
who are not adam kinser they're not
republicans who are trying to both sides
it are saying
if you support a pro-autocracy person
even in the cause of trying to win the
seat
you're taking a risk and that's why
flashing yellow
because if some of these people squeak
through because we played this game
that's very risky now the flip side is
tony in your own missouri
because
last night uh the candidate uh famous
family named bush
uh
uh she she spent a lot of money from
from the
anheuser-busch exactly
the usch not that
right right not the other bush the
original bush the original one not what
was once called the bush crime family
and and their crimes were like you know
jaywalking compared
but but the this anaheiser bush
candidate uh her full name is what
what's her she's uh um
well that's the thing is is that her
name is is what is got her the attention
in saint louis and really when you look
at the vote
yeah when you look at the vote um trudy
bush valentine yeah
valentine thank you um um i'll i'll be
full disclosure i voted for lucas coons
because i i actually felt like that
lucas koontz could beat either eric
schmidt eric greitens or vicky hartzler
which were polling at the top now eric
greitens was actually pulling above
vicky hartzler but when the vote came
down he lost big time i mean he lost big
time and and we've we we watched last
night in the state of missouri that this
rhino talk
is not is not playing well it's not a
it's this trumpism rhino we're going to
kill rhino thing is not playing well no
even in even in missouri now i will i
will as a trumpet right
well i mean
eric schmidt he's a scumbag and the
reason why i say that is because of this
he has spent taxpayers dollars on the
state side the state taxpayers dollars
that our money
suing school districts for the last two
years since the pandemic not only just
to choose what their choice was as far
as how they were going to keep their
staff and their students safe whether it
be mask or distancing or other measures
that they were taking because of the
pandemic but he started to sue school
districts based on surveys that they
were doing which all schools do surveys
they want to know they want to know what
their districts the makeup of their
districts are they want to know what the
feelings are a lot of districts were
actually because missouri um a lot of
people during the pandemic moved out of
the city into the more rural areas they
they had to reconstruct some of their
school district so they were doing
surveys based on that these surveys had
nothing to do with political views or
crt or any of this nonsense but eric
schmidt was using state taxpayer dollars
to sue local school districts which was
costing local people who pay taxes to
that school district money so he was
double dipping and the reason why is to
make sure that he ran a campaign against
the rhino killer
eric greitens he wanted to get the
attention it was all about the attention
to be in the news where did you stand
when you asked him the question who's
president of the united states
well
and that's and that is important with
eric schmidt i think um the importance
there is that eric schmidt was one of
the first attorney generals that joined
texas in their stupid little lawsuit for
the coup d'etat in pennsylvania you
remember before january 6 17 attorneys
general right that's right and he was
one of the first one to jump on board as
soon as ken paxton that criminal down in
texas decided to sue pennsylvania and
michigan and i think arizona and one
other state i believe there's four or
five states that that ken paxton sued
and eric schmidt jumped right on the
bandwagon of the coup d'etat he wanted
to overthrow the the country's vote he
wanted to overcome as he backed off my
question is if you ask him today
we know what carrie lake says what what
does he say about
was the election of fraud is he still
saying the same thing today well i think
i think it's a good question to ask him
and the journalists and democrats should
really pressure him and i hope bush
valentine does pressure him and not only
pressures him on um who is the president
of the united states which is a simple
answer it's a simple easy answer for
anyone for anyone who believes in
democracy but also the question of where
eric schmidt stands on making sure that
women have access absolutely access to
health care and that's why women
candidates this year and this i was for
lucas as well and the full disclosure
you know that i i right one candidate i
have already sent a text this morning
encouraging his people not to be
disheartened they run a great race
way underfunded compared to her she
could write big checks i hope he stays
running all this 39 years old i hope he
keeps running this
iraq and afghanistan veteran who's a
great candidate and stays right on the
ground running
against josh holid in two years that's
he he's absolutely great democratic
nominee what a great idea just holding
that momentum so you know i hope i hope
he doesn't
come away from this feeling disheartened
he's acquitted himself very well and ran
a much closer race than those polls
showed that he would
but but to to the point of trudy bush
valentine
a woman on the ballot
in november
any woman candidate other than carrie
lake and and some of these you know mega
women who are anti-choice
those the women candidates that we're
going to field are going to be stronger
by definition because they can look at a
man they can look at eric schmidt and
say
how dare you
how
dare you say i don't have those rights
and that's a very powerful argument
more women candidates who are running
for house and senate the better off we
are now in your state again in missouri
there's there is
a rhino there's john wood
the that john dempsey put in who was
polling at about lot again polls let's
not say we believe them but it would be
about ten percent
and if that turns out to be true he gets
seven percent
peels off some of that uh middle ground
and it's all going to come out of uh
schmidt
uh
that's an opportunity for trudy bush
valentine to win that senate race i
still don't think this is a
oh absolutely
last night it's not over at all no i
think i think i think you're correct
when you're talking about trudy bush
valentine
if if i were her political strategist
which you know this better than i do i
just yell and scream into a microphone
but if i were her political strategist i
would say i would say trudy there's two
things that you should do two things
is you should find those lucas koontz
voters in those real trump areas and you
should lean into this pink movement
absolutely lean into the pink movement
and if i had advice for lucas goons i
would say don't stop running just like
you would but i would say be out there
pounding the drum right that
in those areas in those areas because he
if you look at the the ideas last night
you run it you ran strong in the rural
areas he did he he ran really strong in
those trump areas which is really
important and is going to be really
important for bush valentine so if they
can band together and create a team here
where they're trying to campaign for
democracy for democracy i think not only
can lucas coons help bush valentine win
that win that seat but he can also set
himself up for a great run against
against uh josh holland i mean josh
hawley
well the other thing too is i think
that's that's really important is is by
by continuing to stay involved and not
just back away from the spotlight and
say okay
i'll come back in a few years or
whatever he will continue to make
himself a name right he will he will be
on he will be on the front lines to say
i was there i was helping i was you know
defending i was doing all these things
so that isn't just like oh he was a
nobody who ran and now he's trying to do
it again for a different seat or
whatever it might be but actually is
there
front and center on the national stage
you'll be like this is where i was and i
didn't back down
to your point one of the things that i
think is really interesting about texas
texas is so
jerry-rigged now even i knew he was
going to think of beto i knew he was
going to be
i had to think it better because
veto has run now for this will be his
third bid for office other than his
house seat
and you know the presidential race
didn't go very well for him
uh the senate race was very close
one of the best senate races anyone can
imagine and again because the system in
texas is so jury rigged against a
democrat statement
and it's going to be worse now with
voter suppression
but greg abbott has been so terrible
and so many things on his watch
the power grid failing uvaldi uh el paso
and who has been on the ground
there in each process who's been doing
what the governor should be doing going
there and hearing food to people yeah
actually showing up to the funeral
for the funerals and being present
that's what veto is so i you know
i'm not even ruling that out in a year
like this and better has done it exactly
right he's in it with courage he's done
it with confronting uh you you've
watched him walk into that room uh
rabbit sitting there and say this is on
you you're responsible
uh you know that that took
cojones as they say
and let's hope that you know a lot of
people recognize who beto is but i i
just want to say
they're that i come back to missouri
because there was great president from
missouri uh from independence where
lucas
now wolves
uh a guy named harry truman uh you all
remember him i know you know i i i i
i met him i shook his hand i've taken a
lot of pictures with him i know i it
well listen i gave him a start in
politics
[Laughter]
from him back before he went out of
business
but here's the thing about harry truman
he he
you know his nickname was give him hell
herod and
he said
uh i'm not giving the republicans hell
i'm just telling
them the truth and they think it's hell
right and that
is what democrats need to do
in september october november they need
to tell the truth about republicans and
they're going to feel like they're in
hell right because
they put themselves there they are now
they've they've they've gone to the dark
side with
orange satan
and that
is going to come back they all have to
defend that right we make them defend
all of those things
anti-democracy anti-women pro-gun
uh anti-environment you name it they're
on the wrong side of it well hell you
had rand paul on the floor yesterday
before the
past talking about how asthma is some
kind of trivial thing and it's not
really service connected and all this
nonsense and he just he just demeaning
veterans even more giving more fodder
for us to politicize because again i
keep saying this over and over everyone
democrats have always been so scared to
politicize stuff but it seems like it's
turning and and i want to show you proof
of that which is this better video
speaking of beto this is a trump voter
and listen to what he says about the
republican party
and beto aurora and why it is so
important that we make sure to
politicize these issues just the issues
like you were talking about not just
like the power grid for for greg abbott
but guns abortion women's rights in
texas i mean all these extreme views
that greg abbott has adopted because he
has to you know the tail is wagging the
dog but listen to this voter here that
they captured and why he's supporting
beto i've been a lifelong republican
voter actually voted for donald trump
absolutely 100 veto supporter um
he's very intelligent he has well
thought out you know approaches and you
spend a little time listening to him
take a little time and listen to what
his has to say about these different
issues because
it's not right or left it's about texas
and that's what we need to hear
we don't hear that
just seemed to get progressively and
progressively far more extreme far away
from the republican party that i
remember you know as a younger person so
i really had to take a hard look at
myself take a hard look at what i
believed and
what i supported and i just found myself
a position where i
could not support that side of the aisle
absolutely a lifelong republican voter
and uh i am voting for beto award for
governor state of texas boom and i think
i think it's paid for by you know betto
uh is that a spot that's running uh uh
beto actually posted that on on twitter
um but this is a gentleman who is a
lifelong republican has and and these
exist
right in the landscape and i think david
that it is so important that people
remember we have not had a national
election we as a nation have not told
the republican party yet what we think
about january 6. and in the meantime in
the meantime they lied and gaslighted us
about gas and about all about the the
war in ukraine they've been gaslighting
us about women's rights and roe and on
and on and on it goes and i think
they've had a miscalculation here and
just as i said in the beginning
i think the pro-democracy part of this
election and hopefully the next two
three four five cycles that
pro-democracy part and that engagement
is starting to bake in the cake because
we've always had republican engagement
baked in the cake with their media
apparatus with their organization with
their gaslighting with their lies but
now we have taken back control as a
pro-democracy
organization in that it's just people
who believe that yes we should have a
vote yes we should have rights and we
should let the people speak we the
people are the government
we are the government
you know i was so happy to hear you say
that because that is government is us
right been my mantra for since ronald
reagan started saying you know pointing
at the government saying that's the
worst thing ever that you know the thing
people fear most is i'm from the
government i'm here to help once the
government was demonized
and it became the other right in that
in 1980 and then you know for the last
40 years
people forget
we
us
everyone here we're the government
police people
teachers fire people people who work on
your roads we're the government that is
the government and and if you make it
the other if you make it some evil thing
of course people are going to be afraid
of it
but when you realize what you just said
we are the government the government is
us not somebody else and we also have a
responsibility to take care of each
other
by being responsible citizens it's not
just a vote you've got to be a citizen
all year long that is
what government used to be about back
with
your friend and mine harry truman
back with fdr who i know you also
remember well
uh
who who understood that that government
could
change people's lives in the tennessee
valley authority or social security or
all of the things that government did
that we take for granted now
but
good luck trying to take that away
um so let me ask you a quick history
question you you know fdr you remember
him well do you remember he had a little
dog
he had a little of course i i remember
yeah going to the house and petting the
dog and okay
here's it you may you know it's it's
morning it's you know it's late night
election results so you're probably
fading a little bit on remembering the
dog
take the picture for you
he had a little dog a little terrier dog
that
was a beautiful dog but the republicans
then like the republicans now got
personal and ugly
they attacked
everything about fdr they attacked his
wife they attacked him it was all
personal invective you know terrible
horrible stuff like we now see coming
out of trump's mouth but they were
pretty bad she's pretty republican and
finally finally the republicans said
something about his little dog
so fdr flipped the script and he said
i can take it
uh if they attack me that's fine but
they're even attacking my little dog
the dog's name was
fala
la and that dog became the most famous
dog in america there's a statue of that
dog right now
as big as fdr statue
and it turned around because it showed
how petty and venal
that the the uh the republicans were so
if you'll allow me a moment of
verisimilitude
um oh he's going to show us his little
dog
this
little dog fala
who i just got
oh and his name is fala named in honor
of fdr the actual full name of phallo
which i didn't know myself you think i'd
remember
was uh named after a scottish
figure from the
1400s named
murray the outlaw of phala hill
so his name is murray the outlaw of
phala hill
but for sure
this is his first on-camera appearance
on
your show your ghost show
so fala say hi to jorge say hi
he's just saying hi to my friend jorge
and
tony and that's gabe hello hi
the audience loves the animals yeah they
love yeah yeah
gage dogs always make a special yeah
they'll hang out in the background you
know sometimes but i think on the dog
point you know there is a especially now
on the internet there's actually a doc
called don't [ __ ] with cats it's a it's
a crazy documentary on netflix but there
is a certain uh rule amongst humans
which is you do not attack
those that are weaker especially animals
right your pets your dogs your cats
whatever it might be
but as soon as you brought up the
terrier i was like
i had this image
of
uh of the wizard of oz right and the
wicked witch saying you know i'll come
after you and your little dog too right
and like that is the republican party
but when you when you start coming after
some that's that's your pet right people
love their pets you know to the ends of
the earth right yep when you go after
that that's like yeah that's that is a
that is a new low that is a low that you
should knock over it's like you don't
attack kids don't attack pets there is a
certain understood rule and as soon as
you break that rule
then you know that that group that is
coming after them is not to be trusted
and gabe to your point about the weaker
that's what trump has and trump ism has
always been about right
punching
hitting more vulnerable people going
after
uh people of color women uh going after
vulnerabilities going after
people with disabilities exactly
down
and of course the the metaphor is you
know the little dog but you know what
they've always done this
who they are
and if we remember
you know uh as has famously been said if
if people tell you who they are believe
them
and republicans are exactly who they say
they are we just have to remind people
of that really well well
the projection is a confession you know
earlier you said that they're they feel
like they're being attacked right or
they feel like they're in hell well it's
only because like you said it is true it
is them feeling the consequences of
their actions there is no cancel culture
they're not getting cancelled it's all
consequences right there is an equal and
opposite reaction to the action that
they took right and so
uh earlier you also mentioned about how
like the government is us and i think a
line from that video from the battle
supporter it was so key and i think so
important as he says this isn't a right
or left issue this is a texas issue this
is about texas and i think at its
fundamental core
it's even more
uh more simple than that right it's not
just texas it's human right it is human
rights human human accessibility to
certain rights that we should have as
citizens of this country and so it's not
a right or a left thing these are these
are uh rights that we should have as
veterans right as women as uh same-sex
couples whatever they might be these are
rights that we should have and it's not
you know it it again it's not a right or
left thing it's just being a decent
human being in caring for those who have
helped
put you
into your position to represent the rest
of people but as soon as you fail them
you know they're in hell
because they're not you know they're
they all of a sudden feel like they're
the victim right and that's what
republicans do unless there's
accountability they do it again right
exactly someone
wisely said about january 6 if they are
not held accountable for it it was a
dress rehearsal
and next time they put on the show
right
next time the curtain comes down on our
democracy so we have we have work to do
we have miles to go before we sleep i'm
going to feed fala here
one more thing before we go david i want
to show you what accountability looks
like this is the ape ap was in the room
wow magnificent women with these
magnificent women when that when the
vote came in and i want to do this
too
let's watch the celebration and and and
the fascist in kansas being held
accountable here watch
[Applause]
dallas
and you see women here of all stripes
this isn't just
cookie cutter these are these are
women of color these are men that are
supporting i want to see the men exactly
and their men are not going to say
it's very important but there's a great
interview coming up um that the ap did
with one of the organizers on the ground
and she talks about they have worked so
hard for the past
year but you know last couple months
to really
you know communicate with voters about
what this was at stake and really what
was at stake was our constitutional
rights and our freedom and so um you
know a coalition of voters across the
political spectrum came together today
and voted no they voted no to protect
their neighbors
they voted no on changing the
constitution
and really
you know demonstrated our free state
routes here in kansas are alive and well
i'm super proud to be from kansas
tonight and i feel like my state just
showed up and boldly told me that they
are going to take care of me and my
female friends and everyone that can get
pregnant in the state of kansas we are
protected tonight
i implore everyone out there
go be kansas be kansas let's
beat kansas and let's show them what
democracy can do let's let me close with
that line there is nothing the matter
with kansas
not a goddess everything is right and
toto
we're going back to kansas that's great
david thank you for joining us i look
forward to this select hearing season
two i hope you join us every single one
i know you joined us before you know
what i i i don't think we're gonna have
the greatest news i hope i'm wrong uh i
don't have a lot of confidence in the
republicans of wyoming but that election
is in a couple weeks right so if you
want to talk after that let's talk after
that because
she is doing what she believes is right
and if the republican voters of wyoming
have lost their minds
then you know so much for it i think
she'll run a closer race than a lot of
people right but but you know it is what
it is in republican primaries now that
and and that
by the way is the great news for the
general election
david for joining us it was so great to
have you everyone stick around we will
be right back
right after these messages thank you
david have a great day you
too we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual partying is not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome oh welcome welcome back to the
show thanks for sticking around to the
break and david bender political
strategist
he's having a little sound issue over
there sounds like the guys are hard at
work at the underground the soros
underground bunker
[Music]
he may or may not get his um
let's see
i think i think your sound is good i
think it's good i think you're good to
go i think you're good again i literally
i literally have a um
a uh
a foam panel um
mic stand in front of me in front behind
my mic so like my mic is set up
obviously like to only pick up what's
around me in front but now i've got this
extra thing that's blocking this screen
so
you know we'll see how it goes but those
guys these guys hard at work down in the
bunker man i know well i gave them most
of the day off yesterday because they
had worked so hard the day before when i
was on site all right right but now
you know they're back at it you know
hold on
we need that bunker right right now so
as long as i sound good you know i've
got like a double kind of panel thing
going on for you no no no you you you
you sound i mean it's okay
oh wow there's a little bit of no well i
mean it is you know yeah i mean if
anyone can see this like moving flap
down here that's uh that's oh is that is
that the foam is that the part of the uh
yeah
but i'll help yeah i'll i'll protect it
for you guys okay well that's great the
best quality i tried well we gotta we
gotta go through the tweety tweets and
drink turns because gabe we got like 45
minutes like we
we may have to go to three hours this is
crazy or this is not crazy do you want
to do the show for three hours every
single day i mean
sure yeah it's it's a lot it's a lot
three but i mean i know i mean there's a
lot of there's a lot of [ __ ] that's uh
they're they're on they're on to you
here they're asking for the uh
i'm working on a design by the way doubt
me doubt me you know i i actually
yesterday i felt really good my mom
called me my mom is a bleeding heart
liberal yeah last night and she was
super excited about some of the stuff
that was happening
and when the kansas vote came in she was
super surprised because i told her weeks
ago i said look kansas is going to go in
the way of democracy here
can't you off the polls and they break
the ballot and you know the on and on
and on it went and i said no no i'm
telling you i'm telling you have
confidence
this stuff this this this
um america is for democracy and against
trumpism uh fascism in a manga hat
it's starting to bake into the cake
so i was telling i've been saying doubt
me doubt me doubt me and i say it about
a lot of different things but um i
believe i was correct yesterday there
was a few things i was wrong on um i
actually in missouri here me and david
and you were talking about it i actually
thought lucas koontz would pull it out
right um i
underestimated the bush name in st louis
a little bit though because those
results came out and she did carry st
louis a little heavy and and i'll tell
you
um to be to be forthright with it the
reason why i voted for lucas koontz is
because i really thought
that he could pull it out and he could
win just like the democrats are putting
money into a trumpers race that this
mayor
in um in michigan
um because they want to win they want to
win look like even robin's going on i
don't want the shirt look i have i
literally have the design up that i'm
working on right now for the doubt i
haven't even seen it folks i haven't
even seen it i'm just i'm trying to
figure out you know should the doubt me
be around the crystal ball or should the
doubt maybe be inside the crystal ball
you know these are things that i mean i
think here's here maybe maybe we should
do a pull because we're going to do a
poll this afternoon because it's going
to be a little different for the bone
and the bone of the week is going to be
this afternoon and then it'll air on
friday just like we always do but but
it'll be this afternoon is when the pole
will come out so we'll put the pull out
a little early but maybe we should do a
poll on
[Music]
what should be inside the crystal balls
should it be the logo the tone of
michael's podcast should it be doubt me
what should be inside
inside that crystal ball yeah i know i
think um the uh the other i just blanked
on me uh i was gonna say
you were gonna say how how oh oh i was
gonna say uh the other well missouri um
uh
right missouri yeah yeah mark mccloskey
right
oh yes yes you're you're talking you're
talking about the the
the um
him and his wife their lawyers they came
out of their house in st louis okay they
pointed they pointed guns
people for walking on the sidewalk black
people walking on the sidewalk by the
way walking on a sidewalk like black is
why they were pointing guns with the
trigger fingers threatening to kill
people
um
yes he did run and he he got trounced as
yeah well he's he's another one that you
know tried to take the
i'm the real victim here
as i point this gun at a bunch of people
who entered this area right and you know
he and his troubles are [ __ ] insane
right but they did their whole media
tour they went on fox news they did this
they did that you know there's a whole
thing where they were trying to say like
they were the real victims they were the
despite the fact that you have a [ __ ]
armed gun a semi-automatic rifle in your
hand and you have it just [ __ ]
pointed and your wife is like ah she's
got a handgun waving it around at people
like okay let's just call what it is you
guys did not really feel afraid you were
not at harm you were not a victim you
were more or less the instigator of that
situation and i am glad to say that that
[ __ ] lost his race his primary
race done out gone so he can go [ __ ]
himself he can't mccloskey can take that
semi-automatic rifle and you know stick
it where you know where that we got a
lot of um suggestions coming in some
people are saying put amanda says put
tony right over the ball and his hands
hovering around doubt me inside no
that's a lot of work that means i gotta
design tony and [ __ ] hey wait a second
wait a second design me i am i am i am
of of a great design my friend i am a
lot of work though man you know it's a
lot of work some people are saying some
people are saying just doubt me on the
shirt no crystal ball no crystal ball
just doubt me
um mj says around the crystal ball use
the soft cotton from the tanks i've got
to go go [ __ ] them
go [ __ ] vote shirt and you can go get
go [ __ ] vote shirts
just go to d the tonymichaels.com
and you can find on both of my merch
stores because i have two because i have
to have it one for the hats everyone
likes the [ __ ] hats um but gabe's got
his i've got his merch store on there as
well
um it says all right so so look they
then stick gabe on a shirt with a part
and blanket okay oh yeah pardon blanket
shirt he wants a wig
this is one of those things where i'm
just like oh do i just hire someone else
to do that he designed i i don't know
maybe maybe we'll characters right maybe
we should maybe we should uh maybe we
should consider that we'll talk about
that after the show um what design we
have wow but i want to i just want to
know how loud is it for other people
um it's not it's not that it's not that
i mean there's there's a lot of
background noise there's a lot of
background noise i can leave guys i can
go no no
we want to surf the tweety tweets and
trendy trends so let's get to it let's
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the
johnny michaels podcast you've reached
the part where we surf to tweet tweets
and train trends and we gotta get to it
now they're asking they're asking about
gabe they want you to stay they say they
can't hear [ __ ] okay um so only tony and
his sensitive ears can hear stuff then i
guess
what what was that what was that uh um
so uh the the alex jones trial has
personally i'm gonna go really fast here
we're gonna be like lightning around
this whole thing we got 40 minutes
lightning round so this is this morning
i'm gonna play a clip yesterday of the
of the judge just absolutely dressing
him down but here this morning he is um
talking more [ __ ] on the stand let's
listen
how did you
feel about that
well when i read the newspaper there was
a 28 million dollar ad buy
all right don't say what you're writing
about so his lawyers like stop stop
saying what you read stop you have to
say what you what did you feel answer
the question listen to what the judge
says here she totally [ __ ] smacks him
in the face
things that you have read are also
hearsay okay because you didn't say them
somebody alex jones
his entire personality is hearsay he's
like oh and he's hearsay jones right oh
i got an email from my crazy uncle and
now it's the truth right like what the
[ __ ] are you because there's also that
other clip which i hope you play oh i'm
going to yeah and but let's let's finish
this one up thing that came from someone
else that you've read or heard you have
to disregard that sentence
you're going to have to disregard a lot
of sentences this guy's a goddamn child
man she is like a parent or a teacher
that's like
okay
now i'm gonna give you the directions or
instructions very slowly
so you have an easy time to understand
them like it's not to like be little or
like be disrespectful just like what the
[ __ ] is going on man you are an adult
who is who is spreading disinformation
i need you to just say
the facts right now and you can't do it
you cannot do it
you are a [ __ ] adult you cannot say
the truth oh this is popcorn man if
people are putting popcorn in the
comments it is i'm telling you now
there's a couple different places to
watch this on youtube but man it's it's
exciting stuff um to watch this because
he just absolutely steps in every time
watch as a sandy hook mom
confronts him right here in the
courtroom and calls him out on his lie
in real time watch this this doesn't
exist that i'm deep state
uh it's just not true look at him
shaking his head you know that that's
the problem i didn't say that
you keep saying i didn't i didn't say
that i didn't say that it's also amazing
to see alex jones go from and the devil
will come down and reign upon the
democrats and now back to the news he
goes from that like if he really
believed what he he was saying right he
didn't want to put on a show like you
see it right now where he's like oh well
i don't i don't know what um i don't
know
i i'm i don't know what uh what uh what
the truth is like he's gone from
straight up just yelling and uh too um
well i i mean i was somebody sent me an
email about something and that's what
they said so i i believed it was truth
and so i'm telling you the truth and
we're gonna get to a clip uh later
because here he lies right to this mom's
face and she calls him out and we're
gonna get to a clip later where the
judge accuses him of lying under oath
twice and people are like why aren't he
being held in contempt and i'm like i
think the judge is like i'm just gonna
let him dig his own grave here yeah and
let this jury just because if he does
and he can't then then it's done right
right right she wants him she wants him
to explain to this jury so let's let's
continue
you keep saying it
why
why
for money
no you made a lot of money while you've
said it no
i know you're
i mean no i didn't say it i promise i
didn't say it watch this this is great
i know you believe me
and yet you're gonna get you're gonna
leave this courthouse yep
and you're gonna say it again on your
show
you're saying no you just did it
because it doesn't exist oh she's so
[ __ ] sick of this guy just sick and
tired of him and ain't even about the
money anymore for her she just like just
admitted you pile of [ __ ] tell your
audience
we're real we weren't crisis actors this
wasn't [ __ ] some [ __ ] hoax we were
real kids that had real lives and they
were our children and because of your
lies people are now you know attacking
us saying that we are liars and that we
aren't real and that we're paid people
by [ __ ] soros
like that is the disgusting lies that
that alex jones will spread and the
victims
that lay waste
in his path are these parents that have
to not only deal with the loss of their
kid but then have to deal with the fact
that there's a community of people who
say that those kids didn't even exist in
the first place
he's such a pile of [ __ ] and here the
judge calls him out on his [ __ ] line
she actually had to she had actually had
to get the uh
the the the the jury to leave because he
kept [ __ ] mine and then watch how she
dresses him down here
just it i cannot say to this jury
that you complied with discovered
that so the audio's a little tough here
because i actually clipped this from um
the youtube channel and they have the
room mic but they're not tapped into the
actual mics here
but it's gotten so many views because of
what she dresses and down here she said
you cannot say that you that you
complied with discovery that is a lie
watch this that is not true
you may not say it again
you may not say it again so she's
warning him you cannot say that again
and she's gonna have to keep doing this
like she's gonna have to keep doing this
where she has to keep telling him stuff
that he can't say so he doesn't say it
you may not tell this jury that you are
better that is also not true
you may have filed for bankruptcy
i don't know that but i've heard that it
doesn't put that doesn't make a person
or a company bankrupt
you're already under oath to tell the
truth
you've already violated that oh twice
today
in just those two examples
it seems
absurd to instruct you again
that you must tell the truth while you
testify yet here i am you must tell the
truth
while you testify
this is not your show
that's one of the best moments when she
points at the stand that he's sitting on
and she's like this microphone this seat
here this is not your [ __ ] show this
is my courtroom
this is not your show you do not just
get to say [ __ ] and she continues on
here but i also i have another clip um
here um apparently uh alex jones has
went full written house here um
apparently yeah let me see if i can get
this uh this well the uh
the
well i'll only play this clip and i'll
see what i'm gonna say okay and um let
me let me uh uh see what alex jones uh
uh it looks like
looks like he's gonna he's gonna weep
here this is he's going full written
house here this is this just came in i
believe this is uh just about 10 minutes
ago mr jones you know how an iphone
works right you've had like one text
message for several years now
yeah
what does it mean if the messages are in
blue
whose messages are those whose phone is
this taken from
i don't know
i mean i just i turn the phone over and
say take stuff off can i have you look
in the very bottom below the
very bottom left corner
is that the phone number
yes
so you did get my text messages
and they said you didn't nice trick
yes mr jones indeed
you didn't give this text message too
this is hilarious because what he's
trying to do is he's trying to dance
around what what we just heard the judge
tell him not to say
which is i complied with discovery
because that's what he's doing here he's
saying i did give you the text messages
yeah i'm not a bad guy i gave you the i
have a feeling
this is just an assumption right
that alex jones
has [ __ ] vapor rub
on his fingertips
and he's raw and he rubs underneath his
eyes to make them water because if
anyone is taking vaporub like you or you
know you put it on your chest like like
vicks like victims yeah like vicks right
like you put it on to like you know help
kind of like
oh okay you know you you get things it
is it is intense it is a opens you up
right right it is a method to get people
to like fake cry especially if they're
having trouble you know on set and like
i can't really cry it's like all right
these normal methods aren't working like
we can use a hack this is one of those
hacks where you put the [ __ ] vix
underneath here to get
it get that going in your eye to make
them water i wouldn't be surprised if
alex jones did that very same thing and
put [ __ ] vix and vaporwub like under
his eye
what a little [ __ ] let's listen to what
he says about these text messages
because i i'm guessing this is not going
to go well for him accusing
uh uh i did give you oh so i did give
you your text message she did get my
text messages i like how he likes to
come see oh nice try nice trick yeah and
let's listen you don't you don't know
where this came from do you know where i
got this no
mr jones oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i think
it it feels like that this lawyer he's
setting him up for the sandy hook is
gonna smack him in the face with a
shovel here like this is gonna be so
great i can't i can't wait to see what
happens here but the
the attorney's like oh baby oh baby you
just walked into a dummy yeah yeah you
just walked in that's until the moment
alex jones stepped in a huge pile of
[ __ ]
the narrator says let's listen
did you know that 12 days ago
12 days ago
your attorneys messed up and sent me an
entire digital copy of your entire cell
phone with every text message you've
sent for the past two years and when
informed did not take any steps to
identify it as privileged or protected
in any way
and as of two days ago it fell free and
clear into my possession and that's how
i know you lied to me when you said you
didn't have to text messages oh look at
that
did i say a shovel i meant a piece of
really heavy mining equipment holy [ __ ]
those guys out there the guys that are
digging the bunker yeah that lawyer just
took a piece of equipment like that and
smacked him over the face with it
oh my god look at his face here he is
what
what my textbook all of my text messages
what two years did he say 12 years
two years oh two years like twelve days
ago nine days ago now there's a part of
me was like holy [ __ ]
what on there is from january 6th that's
right because we are we are within two
years
and now this is part this is within
discovery of this trial uh-oh
look at him look at him freaking out i
think i think he just [ __ ] his trump
brand diaper here what do you think
oh yeah 100
what the [ __ ] oh my god this is awesome
all right let's listen did you know that
i see i told you the truth this is your
perry makes a moment i gave them my
phone
and then mr jones you need to answer the
question
no i don't know what's happened but i
mean i told you i gave him a follower
oh he's so [ __ ] here he is so funny
well i told him i gave him the phone oh
answer the [ __ ] question man answer
the [ __ ] question what the best part
is is that not only does he not know
that this guy has had his phone for two
weeks
for two weeks yeah but but did but the
attorneys did know and didn't [ __ ]
tell him that they made a mistake
because they knew they made the mistake
because he said i had to let them know
to give them notice to say rather this
information that i received was really
part of discovery or not
because he received it
by accident
they sent him the entirety of the text
message apparently holy [ __ ] let's
listen you said
you said in your deposition
you searched your phone
you said you told down the text did the
search function for sandy hook that's
what you said mr jones correct and i had
several several different phones with
this number but i did yeah
of course i mean that's why you got it
that's not right
my lawyer said it to you but i'm hiding
it okay
mr jones
[Laughter]
she's like
do
not make me [ __ ] repeat myself you
peaceless
oh my god oh my god this piece of [ __ ]
you know you know i wonder if she's got
a hershman justice bat underneath that
desk and she's like look here
[ __ ]
one false move dude the [ __ ] the mr
jones
her side eye which is like
look at this mr jones and then turns
over and she's like do not make me
[ __ ] [ __ ] slap you in front of
everyone here and everyone will be like
yeah please do do that slap this
[ __ ] across the face mr jo mr
jones oh my god this is fantastic you
know what you know what i i love more
than anything about the last week is
that we really are proving that women
women are and marger taylor green is
absolutely wrong on this women are the
superior sex right they will deliver us
democracy this is exactly why women
should be in charge this exact moment
right here on the screen where she is
dressing down alex jones and telling him
to keep his mouth
shut don't do it don't do what i think
you're gonna do which is do your [ __ ]
[ __ ] on your show because this is
not your show this is a classic moment
this is historic moment right here on
the screen this is a moment that will be
in history of why you should not go on a
tirade and keep lying even when your
troll even when you're troll following
continues to to send death threats and
threaten and harass the people that you
are lying about and defaming and and
causing libel against them when their
children died from a maniac with an
assault style rifle weapon of war
ripping apart your children in a school
where they're supposed to be safe 26 of
them to be exact this is a moment that
you will remember of a woman saying
enough from you [ __ ] enough from
you let's continue
just answer questions there's no
question
mr bankster also only asks questions
sure
oh setting the record straight with them
what's the did you send me another link
here i sent you another one uh yeah this
is one i saw yesterday but kaelin uh
reminded me of it
it's
it's a whole thing about alex jones
chewing he has
something in his mouth right and she's
like spit out the gum and then he says
it's not gum and what follows
is [ __ ] nuts let's listen to this
neck and [ __ ] which is also 100 on brand
for someone like alex jones where he's
trying to make a spectacle of this and
trying to be like oh all right all right
and so you'll see well then this is why
the judge is so pissed off and why her
patience yeah she's so short she's like
uh [ __ ] me for one she might be like
[ __ ] me for taking this case two i you
know this is definitely a case that will
be remembered
but three i think again she's like oh my
god ah jesus like i didn't know it was
gonna be this [ __ ]
unbearable
to deal with right he's such a [ __ ] box
he's such a [ __ ] box and she knew that
but she has to experience it in real
time or he can't he's like a [ __ ]
child and he can't control himself and
that's what this trumpism [ __ ] is and
that's why i'm so happy that this judge
is absolutely using
what eric hershman has hanging behind
him a bat of justice
to beat this stuff down but watch i've
watched this clip too watch how alex
jones tries to lie i think he swallowed
the gun but let's
i i've been watch that there it goes on
and uh
he says that he's sorry and we'd ask
that the entire apartment
get your gun out mr jones
what is it
because you're not allowed food or gum
of any kind in the courtroom this is so
funny she's like
it's like um it's like a mom in church
man she has to tell him she's like
[ __ ] got the gum in my hand spit the
gum out with my hand god damn it do i
need to go do i need to come down there
do i need to come down there give me the
gum he's such a [ __ ] child what the
[ __ ] let's watch
i i have my penis
and that's the [ __ ] lie i don't
believe that [ __ ] it's causing you to
like it's one thing for him to say to be
like i'm chewing on my gauze i got my
tooth pulled right and then just it's
one of those things where it's like
if somebody says
something you're like yeah whatever okay
but when you repeat it back and you say
you're chewing on your gauze
[Laughter]
you have to be like wait sorry did i
catch that right did i just catch that
right are you really you really trying
to tell me right now that you're not
chewing on gum you're chewing on gauze
especially when you have your tooth
pulled and you have a hole in it which
by the way you would have stitches and
even if the stitches were [ __ ] pulled
you would not be like for someone you
know who has had their wisdom teeth
taken out i remember that [ __ ] where
it's like we're gonna you know stitch it
up you'll have gauze the first night you
have your vicodin and then if the
stitches open up like that's how it is
you just have to make sure you have to
clean it out but you should not be
chewing
gauze or gum a week and a half later
when your [ __ ] is open watch what he
tries to do he tries to show her like
he's a little child like no really see
the dog did it look look what is this
no i didn't want you to answer my
question no
i was massaging
holding my mouth with my tongue okay
right
i don't want i don't want to see the
internet i don't i don't wanna i don't i
don't i don't why did you take the dog
[ __ ] out of the front yard i don't wanna
see it what
you smeared it on the walls oh my god i
don't wanna see that he's such a dumb
[ __ ] that is
that is like it is like it is that
moment of like do i need to pull this
car around do i need to pull this
[ __ ] car around and go back home
right now
like the uh
it's also one of those things where like
as a parent you're like where the hell
did you even get that like you you've
been right here the whole time where did
you get this [ __ ] [ __ ] did you just
like
it's one of those moments where as a kid
or as a parent you're like
how was this even possible how did you
do this
right
what oh my god well speaking of [ __ ]
boxes here's king shitbox himself randy
listen to this [ __ ] guy
describe describe that the ailments that
veterans have are just tiny little
ailments and according gabe according to
the cdc now rand paul loves the scene he
loves scientists when he can weaponize
science against veterans and getting
their healthcare he's all for that baby
he is all for that denying veterans or
healthcare by cdc that that pseudo
science as he says let's listen to this
piece of [ __ ] care of our veterans and
keep our country strong
this bill puts our economy though at
risk by creating presumptions of service
connection for the most common
availments you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] now
again this is the debate yesterday
before they took the vote
again on the pact act now this brazen
piece of [ __ ] right this brazen piece of
[ __ ] after all the stuff even ted cruz
it turned the vote for ted cruz after he
got in a stupid little battle with jon
stewart which ted cruz definitely wanted
to vote against this thing but because
of his big [ __ ] mouth he had to vote
for it right which the same way alex
jones are big [ __ ] mouth but even
this guy even this [ __ ] scumbag
saying this vile [ __ ] and having these
vile views still
still couldn't muster up enough courage
to say that asthma the chronic asthma
caused by inhaling toxins
somehow isn't isn't service connected
and watch how he uses the cdc this
[ __ ]
for example this legislation creates a
presumption of service connection for
vietnam veterans for hypertension
but according to the cdc 50 of men and
44 percent of women in the united states
have hypertension
more than 60 percent of people over the
age of 60 have hypertension
in total the cdc estimates that 106
estimates that 116 million americans
have hypertension
so not only does rand paul
absolutely [ __ ]
all over veterans here he's [ __ ] all
over americans even because what he's
saying is the government
the government providing any money to
help their citizens with hypertension
is is bad for our economy
he is such a dumb [ __ ] what a
stupid piece of [ __ ] to think that that
people being healthy is bad for our
economy this is really dumb [ __ ] i keep
saying this over and over and over again
common people in this [ __ ] country
have one thing to trade one piece of
capital and that is their labor and they
require require their health to trade
their labor which means our best
interests as a country should be in
their health so they can trade their
labor so our economy can keep turning
this is really easy [ __ ] to understand
right and we're not right the fact of
the matter is ron rand paul understands
it oh yeah
yeah and robert says rand paul speaks
speaking gives me hypertension
that service connected enough really
honestly right but also it's like again
it goes back to this whole thing about
how republicans are
anti-air americans every single
anti-every anti-human right right you've
got them voting against anti-human
trafficking bill which means they're
pro-human trafficking they're voting
against health care for the people that
said oh we're so grateful that you were
willing to sacrifice your life and put
your life on the line so we could have
you know freedom and security and all
these things like
you
the republican party doesn't give a [ __ ]
about these people at all right and the
veterans will remember the fact that
republicans flip-flopped voted for it
voted against it and then voted for it
again when nothing on the on the bill
actually changed between june 16th to
july to to the beginning of august
august 2nd right
that is who the republican party is and
now people are beginning to wait and
we're talking about it you know we've
been talking about you know for a while
now that the people are beginning to
wake up and realize
that republicans don't actually care
about anything they don't have american
values they do not care about americans
they will [ __ ] you over the first chance
they get if it's a paycheck that they'll
get from lobbyists or it's some other
thing that they're using for an ulterior
motive right they will [ __ ] us over
100 percent
all the time well elisa points it out
here on youtube rand paul hasn't even
visited the flood the poor flood victims
that's because rand paul doesn't give a
[ __ ] he doesn't give a [ __ ] he'll take
he'll talk about that he'll take
government aid money for anything but
then we'll try to restrict those things
for other states he's like ted cruz ted
cruz wanted to restrict the
government funding for uh for the
hurricane uh that was in uh new york uh
new jersey area which i think was
specifically new york
um
and then when they had the
the the power outage the grid failed the
snow storm he was like hey government
can we get some money
right like that is the republican party
you know they want it for themselves but
they won't share it with other people
well
people can go [ __ ] themselves that's
what i'm saying you gotta hate rand paul
but you gotta love his name or uh amanda
points it out here if i was rand paul's
neighbor i'd be crapping in his lawn
daily newspaper in hand and
all think we should get a gospel let me
get over the fence yeah
let's get up let's get a gofundme
together get amanda
a house near rand paul everyone loves
rand paul's neighbor let's finish let's
listen to what this [ __ ] box how he
winds it up here
the legislation also creates a
presumption of service connection for
global war on terror veterans for asthma
the cdc estimates that one in 12 people
have asthma which is approximately 25
million americans
oh well those 25 million americans can
go [ __ ] themselves along with the
veterans that i'm going to vote against
today right right i mean forget about
the veterans that i'm going to [ __ ] on
those 25 those
those 25 million americans yeah [ __ ]
them too [ __ ] this i mean
just the fact that you know people like
rand paul who by the way is a total
waste of space someone that we're always
waiting on when it comes to vote the
person who is 100
going to stall a vote because he has to
have the last word which is always some
dumb [ __ ] statement like this
amendment he had right
which got voted down right it was like
seven seven to ninety right him him and
two other dumb [ __ ] dude marcia
blackburn ron johnson
the common sack of [ __ ] that you would
that you would see yeah
pro insurrectionist type people right
right
exactly here um and speaking of uh
trying to frame up [ __ ] that isn't true
like rand paul just did here here's i
don't know who the [ __ ] this is i'm
reading this chiron and i don't know if
that's true
right um well here's here's the thing
is she talks about kansas here but
listen how she frames it up this is
[ __ ] gross
oh my god they're so stupid
and indeed as the wall street general
editorial board james freeman has
predicted that this reversal
of roe by the supreme court yeah it's a
return to democracy
oh my god so here's where
tony wait wait right this overturning of
roe v wade is a return to democracy
that's what she's claiming here oh
that's interesting i'm slowly gonna
morph into uh mitch mcconnell man i said
[ __ ] you is this mitch mcconnell's
sister or it might be you it could be
his sister i don't know no maybe it's
maybe it's also man what a what a what
a pause moment right well i like the
possum
you know the the craziest part is she is
about to she's about to set a ball on a
t that taking away people's rights in
this country to their bodily autonomy to
making sure that more rights can be
taken away with that decision because
that decision just didn't take away
bodily autonomy for women it extends the
ability for republicans to make the
claim that they can take away your
[ __ ] marriage rights right if we
could take that right away right that's
real democracy that's real democracy
when you're taking people rights away
she literally is gonna make this
argument listen to this [ __ ] vile
nonsense
where you put now back in the hands of
legislate uh legislatures and in the
hands of voters the ability to
uh go to the ballot box and and decide
for themselves
no the reason why they have to do this
the reason why you're forcing them to
use democracy is because you're
authoritarians you are pieces of fascist
[ __ ] that's the reason why we have to
engage and now mobilize against you but
there is something here right there
she can't she she's [ __ ] you know
right she's dancing around because this
is what's happening she's saying that
supreme court you know right
pro-democracy taking away the rights was
totally this was their intention
the supreme court chose to take this
right away
these people voting had a choice
to keep it or or or you know uh make it
or leave it right right and she's she's
uh she's like
you know she's balancing between the
line here she's either for the supreme
court taking this away or she's either
for these people having the right to
choose stage rights right like if that
really is the case right you she needs
to decide which one is which you either
take it away from everyone
and not let them have a choice
or you allow them to have that choice
because you want to talk about states
rights right and i would guarantee
that probably a majority if not all of
these states because they are so heavily
blue and not actually read due to
redistricting gerrymandering would
actually vote the same way
that kansas did well paula makes a good
point she says my bodily autonomy should
not even be an issue it should be a
given and linda on facebook points out
when your freedoms is gone you're more
free this is really stupid this is wrong
there is no takes these backsies here
like you can't give it and
but that really is what she's doing here
because they realize that democracy is
about to be mounded on top of them right
they are about to really see what real
democracy is in this midterm i believe
we are going to see more democracy in
this midterm than we saw in the 2020
election and i believe because of this
midterm we will see even more democracy
happening in 2024 but this election is
the most important one in front of us
now
and i think they're preparing themselves
that hey
hey folks we pissed these people off and
they're going to use the democracy
against us like we've been trying to use
it against them to take it away watch
what she says here at the end where a
state wants to stand on abortion policy
and the voters in kansas did that very
thing so that all blows up the democrat
narrative of the supreme court is
destroying our democracy and in fact
they're saving it
so so again back to linda's point if i
take away your freedoms you're more free
to choose like this is really stupid
[ __ ] and again again they're losing
control of their narrative they're
losing their grip on this liberty
freedom patriotism [ __ ] as because folks
the road decision is in complete line
with january 6. it is trumpism to its
[ __ ] core taking away your bodily
autonomy and and cheating to win
elections to make sure they cheat and
buy supreme court justices to take away
your rights because they know democracy
will not afford them the ability to take
away your rights that is trumpism to its
[ __ ] core it's authoritarianism and
that is what they're terrified of and
that's why they're trying to frame it up
again like they're [ __ ] pro-democracy
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
nonsense with that [ __ ] i'm sick of
hearing this stuff uh let's see what
what other videos i got a ton of videos
here yeah you got them let's play them
we got six minutes man let's go to carry
lead round your speed round number seven
seconds let's listen to carrie [ __ ]
here there is no path to victory for my
opponent and we won this race
period
so this is last night uh as she was uh
doing going to declare victory she did
declare victory now it appears that she
has won
but the problem is is yesterday she was
saying oh it's all fraud it's all fraud
the election's gonna be rigged and now
it's now she won so what does that mean
right exactly i mean she's like you know
her
the other thing too is she was tweeting
yesterday and was like stay in line they
legally must let you vote if the lines
go past it's seven o'clock which is
something you would tell everyone right
like it's something to remember like
that's democracy that's democracy you're
right you were in line you're good to
vote you know
especially for people who are like
trying to make it back from work like
totally get that and that's why we allow
that right
but then she's saying very important you
got to stay in line gotta stay in line
it is hilarious how these people
these fascists are willing to tell their
own voters when it really does matter
because she knows it wasn't gonna be a
landslide victory it was gonna be
[ __ ] close and she had to tell people
don't leave don't leave make sure that
you're in line if you're there by at
seven you can vote right and then she
goes on to talk about how there's this
widespread election fraud in arizona
during the 2020 election what the [ __ ]
changed between 2020 using those systems
and 2022 with the with a primary right
nothing changed nothing changed and the
fact that she was setting up for the
possibility that oh this election was
rigged which she has also not even shown
any evidence of and still needs to i
believe for the 2020 election but she
goes out here to say it's going to be
rigged it's going to be rigged it's
going to be rigged and then she wins and
it's like
so it wasn't real right right well
here's another one here's another one of
these trump lodites that
was trying to declare victory before he
won he got [ __ ] trounced yesterday
ellen greitens the rhino hunter is a
ratio hunter now uh he got hunted oh my
god ratio hunting big time he was he
posted and i might show it but he posted
on twitter um about his victory uh rally
or whatever and oh my god they ratioed
the [ __ ] out of him but let's minus
touch did a video of his of him
declaring victory before he had victory
here
and it doesn't go well for eric let's
let's find out let's find out how well
it goes happy election day everybody
yeah i voted included make sure you do
too get your family your friends out and
make sure everybody's voting today we're
honored to be endorsed by president
donald trump
what wait a second wait
he was endorsed by donald trump i that's
what he's claiming yeah i guess so let's
see what else he thinks immediately
followed by the endorsement of donald
trump jr of course we have to do what
daddy does right we are going to have a
fantastic maga victory today again
they're gonna have a fantastic mega
victory
i mean he's gonna win yeah well he's a
naga loser who do you think he has duct
tape to the rail on off screen oh who do
you think maybe kimberly gilfoy i don't
know i mean there was a probably someone
there
i had a facetime call with kimberly
guilfoyle and she was trying to get me
to vote for eric greitens well we'll go
to that after after this video let's see
let's see how
eric's victory maga victory here played
out against the establishment at the end
of the day love beats lies at the end of
the day our faith is going to beat their
fear let's go out and let's strike a
blow for magga
eric greitens
he's so tough
oh wait
[Laughter]
i really i really wish that that brett
had edited this video to go down
like playing the sound effect like the
price is right you know
i i think i think we could i think we
can take it we can put that in and we
can send it out i don't think
we'll see we'll check with him
yeah with him
we'll make a couple different versions
with the with the yeah yeah just a bunch
of random like maybe even one at the end
where eric greitens comes up and then
josh hawley's like running away because
you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're so scared
yeah
i mean they're connected because you
know his investigation into into eric
greitens when josh hawley was the
attorney general right right and then he
kind of let that one skirt by he's like
i don't have the power to do it they
kind of have they kind of have they were
they were brenemies right uh-huh they
had a bromance and they were frenemies
and they were enemies all at the same
time really yeah um i mean
if he got in they could have been bros
again dude oh man i actually had awards
i have insider information about that
investigation now i'm not gonna i was
gonna [ __ ] with it if
if um if eric got this but now that he's
cascaded into you know uh
victory i mean maybe maybe you should do
something about it i mean like you know
it doesn't hurt to put it out there well
i mean i would much rather try to dig
some dirt up on um eric eric the other
schmidt yeah yeah yeah the other one but
here's here's the phone call
that you the weird phone call you
received from kimberly guilfoyle and
then then we we're running out of time
but let's listen to this
wait
why is she calling me kimberly did
junior make you call me get out there
and vote for eric greitens eric greitens
that guy's a psychopath a true patriot
who puts america first kimberly did you
hear what i just said the guy is insane
he tied up his former hairdresser in his
basement coerced her into giving him
oral sex and then tried to blackmail her
with nude photos the favorite of the
maga movement why do you sound like
you're reading a script we need eric's
leadership wait is eric greitens holding
you hostage
maybe kimberly was duct taped to the
rail i don't know no i mean
inspiring minds would like to know
it seems as though she was possibly held
against her will she had a mic clipped
up you know couldn't see her hands only
could see from here up and she was
saying something that seemed to be
reading off some sort of ransom note or
script right well i guess the moral of
the story here is when you when you lie
in bed with
with people like don junior and kimberly
guilford oh my god i almost yeah
sorry uh sorry to the audience but it
when you when you when you when you
associate yourself
uh with folks like that you're gonna
lose and when you associate yourself
with this idea that you're gonna kill
dissidents this this
this great
great great
history of fascism where you're going to
kill dissidents because they don't agree
with you you're going to [ __ ] lose
and i believe i believe that
there is going to be a lot of losses for
republicans and these [ __ ] people who
claim to be rhino hunters out there so
stay tuned every single weekend right
here on the tony michaels podcast monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter and
twitch don't forget to go follow on on
twitter at tonymichaelspod the bone end
of the week poll will come out today
today it's going to release today oh
yeah we got some nominees baby we will
play it on friday on friday we will play
bone of the week but go vote today also
follow the youtube channel subscribe you
can vote there and download every single
episode on apple spotify and google
gabe i'm glad you could join us even
with the sound and i had a great time
with david bender today yeah it was
great david great blast a great great
great and we met fala that was great
that's right that's right
who's who's gonna dog the dogs
not us
not us
all right
thanks for coming here great tuesday
yesterday great primary day let's keep
this democracy going don't stop keep
pounding the drum
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking